lunch money time
bang bang what's going on guys monday
morning here i am with the beautiful
intelligent polina ivalova marinova
pompliano p-i-m-p
while while she's trying to get rich for
us let's just try to get our lunch money
right don't forget
block five is now the sponsor of lunch
money you can go to blockfi.com
lunch money and you can earn up to 8.6
apy
in an interest-bearing account
no-brainer there's risk do your own
research i'm an investor
and a user big user of the product love
it absolutely
think it's the future 8.6 apy go check
it out
lunchmoney.org sorry blockfy.com lunch
money
there you won't forget the url all right
what is up in the luxury retail space
retail rents are plummeting across new
york city
as america's glitzy shopping districts
turn into ghost towns
so apparently average asking rents among
16 major retail quarters in manhattan
declined for the 11th consecutive
quarter
falling to 688 dollars per square foot
in the second quarter
so this is the first time that retail
rent so think of
retail stores their rent in new york
city has fallen below
700 a square foot since 2011
it shouldn't be surprising wait what
happened in 2011
well there was 2011 was obviously the
global financial crisis right but it
takes
there's ramifications but there's this
trend over the last 11 quarters
of rents falling now what we're seeing
though is there's this acceleration
of a trend that was already underway of
course it is going to
end up going lower uh and i don't think
that people really were expecting this
what i think is more interesting is the
fact how many of them are going
bankrupt a lot of them are going
bankrupt and the ones that aren't
yet bankrupt are suing to get out of
their leases on fifth avenue like
high-end
handbag maker valentino's like i'm suing
i need to get out of here
barney's is vacated neiman marcus is
shutting his doors for good
there's all kinds of people going
bankrupt
people don't want to go to the store
anymore there's amazon and sure
there are some stores that people will
go to but for the most part across the
sector retail is getting crushed
e-commerce is exploding one goes down
the other goes up
exactly how business works i will say i
saw a line in front of gucci the other
day
yeah but gucci's probably running a
special i don't know but
i mean fifth avenue is dead and it's not
just that people are buying on amazon
it's that people don't want to be inside
stores after
you know yeah i'm using amazon shopify
right gumroad all these as
ecommerce obviously there's not tons of
people buying a 50 000
valentino high-end handbag whatever the
hell that is it's a bag
don't insult it by calling it a purse
okay so a 50 000 valentino
bag like i just i just go get a trash
bag from underneath the sink it will be
good
uh i don't think a lot of you are buying
50 000 bags
on amazon or on the internet so i think
that just generally people like wait a
minute maybe i don't need that fifty
thousand dollar
bag i could just go use the trash bag
underneath the city no but i was talking
more that's not what they're saying at
all but
um i was more talking about the fact
that these stores were
shut until recently like completely shut
they
people could not go shop inside of them
of course that's why sales are down
for those of you that don't know this uh
there was a point in my life where i
lived out of a duffel bag
and inside the duffel bag was a trash
bag i think that is when i met you
that's what planet met me i was a
one-man wrecking crew
and i just would go city to city and
meet all my friends tell them about when
we
decided to move in together uh polina
did a lot of packing and uh
we were ready to move to our new place
and she goes where's all your stuff and
i go right here and i just picked up one
duffel bag and she goes
what do you mean and i said this is all
i have
why do i need anything else that's all
you had and she was like but look at all
the stuff i have and i was like well
guess who we just figured out who the
smart person in this relationship was
because i only got this and i had a bag
and i had a backpack for my computer and
i was ready to go
off to anywhere in the world we recently
retired the handbag or the duffel bag
duffel bag yeah i got a hole in it
so i just taped it up for a while all
right what's going on microsoft
does anybody want this um i did
microsoft confirms talks to buy tick
tock in the u.s
aims to finish deal by september 15th is
this for real
yeah so hold on a second so first of all
trump was like
i'm gonna ban tick tock executive order
on saturday
and then like people woke up on saturday
like oh it's tick tock and it was still
there
so how yeah of course i mean look this
stuff takes time could he do it by an
executive order absolutely but if you're
going to come out and
through executive order and ban
something you better know exactly how
you're going to get it off people's
phones
you better know exactly how you're going
to shut it down yeah nobody got time for
that all that kind of stuff uh you saw
the tick tock stars being like oh go
follow me on my social media accounts
like hurry hurry hurry
you saw yeah people going to triller
going to bite to these other uh
platforms what i just don't want to
download another thing
well tick tock is not going to die
right but if it's microsoft will kill it
no i mean possibly like i mean look like
like we talked about previously
microsoft has killed a lot of things but
also that github has thrived and
continues yeah but that's
super rare so i think the key here
really comes down to
um if they ban it is a real ban
can kids use like here's here's a crazy
idea can kids use a mobile vpn to still
get on tick tock
if they can then all of a sudden do kids
just become experts in mobile vpns
is it once all the big stars are like oh
this is stupid i'm not going to count on
kids understanding mobile vpn so i'm
just going to go to a different platform
then does everybody run over to triller
or byte or you know whatever it is
i don't know but at the end of the day
uh i feel like microsoft's gonna make a
play here
there's pretty much their only deal that
they have to try to win this space
trump agreed to give bite dance 45 days
to cut a deal with microsoft over
tick tock okay so but i don't understand
you yourself said the other day that
we're not sure like
you know how much um how close are they
still gonna be to the chinese government
or the parent company or whatever
even if microsoft buys them why is trump
okay with that if he's worried about
national security well what microsoft is
saying is that they're going to
basically take over the code base
they're going to delete all data that
exists anywhere else they won't share
data like they're saying all the things
that would
be necessary to make it a us-based
company but there's a lot of people
online in silicon valley
i'm not going to name names but they're
very well known individuals who are very
well respected
who are making the claim that microsoft
should not be allowed to do this and
microsoft of all people
who does a lot of business with the ccp
is
merely going to kowtow to the communist
party
yes like basically if the communist
party says to do something microsoft
will do it as well
uh because they uh k-o-w-t-o-w
it's all right i read the internet i've
got addiction
act in an excessively subservient manner
look at you with the awards
we watched a spelling bee documentary
the other day that's probably why
no but just so you guys know you can
call me webster from now on
um but if they're cow towing to the
uh chinese communist party then what's
the difference between the chinese
owning it
versus microsoft owning it and so maybe
i should just own it well maybe what
they should do is they should ban
anyone from buying it if you have
considerable business and revenue coming
from the ccp
okay um donald trump will announce a new
action in the coming days related to
chinese software companies that his
administration views as a threat to u.s
national security did you see i knew we
were going to go from tick tock just the
chinese software companies
just like a little circle it's all thing
this is one of the biggest threats right
now
uh in the u.s china showdown
there's an economic battle there's now
this technology industry battle
uh ultimately you have the east and the
west coming to head
and they're fighting and they're gonna
find everything they possibly can but as
i said previously
the chinese have been doing this to the
united states for a very long time
and so if we do it back to them
it evens the playing field we're simply
going to apply the same standards that
the chinese applied to us-based
companies
to chinese-based companies in the us
we're following the
we're following their their lead so i
don't see what the problem is go ahead
what's next
do you have any opinions no you have no
opinions
plain doesn't like talking about this
stuff no i just don't like talking to
you about this stuff
okay wait wait why because you're just
you go on your right
all right let's go hey do you see right
here actually i'm not going to count
here do you see right here that is
vitamin c
that we pour in drinks and i drink it
every day twice a day i will not say
that it has health benefits but i will
say that it's not a bad idea just in
case
all right what's up you're so annoying
say you're annoying count toads
and for those who don't speak bulgarian
won't leave me alone go ahead
i was gonna use that as the riddle come
on let's go
okay a group of pac-12 i don't know what
the pac-12 is
it's a conference in college football
okay
like the sec like a group yeah like the
sec a group of football players from
multiple schools have penned a letter in
the players tribune threatening to opt
out of fall camp
and gain participation unless their
demands for fair
treatment safety regulations and
concerns over racial justice for college
athletes are met
by the conference good for these
students oh you agree with that oh yeah
you don't even know what their demands
are
i do i read it what is their demands
okay so oh you read the internet oh
look at this winning strategy of course
this article is not going to have their
demands
they want it no they want they want
racial justice
what is that what does that mean what
does racial justice mean i
i'm not sure they elaborated okay um
just saying that's a hard thing to to
request but go ahead
what do you mean it's not or is that how
is that a hard thing because it's not
measurable
instead another one of their demands
which is very measurable
is reportedly again it hasn't come out
yet but reportedly
is they want 50 of revenue distributed
to players
and they want lifetime health insurance
okay
both of those things are measurable i
actually agree there should be racial
justice
you just got to come up with something
that is measurable so that you can
basically hold
but the confidence they do have they do
have measurable things for the racial
justice
form a permanent civic engagement task
force made up of leaders experts of our
choice and university and conference
administrators to address outstanding
issues such as racial injustice and
college sports
two in partnership with the pac-12 two
percent of conference revenue would be
directed to
by players to support financial aid for
low-income black students
community initiatives and development
programs and then three form
annual pac-12 black college athlete
summit with guaranteed representation of
at least three athletes of our choice
from every school i think that's
reasonable i think it's very specific
and it's measurable i think that the
first two
make a lot of sense i think that they'll
have a hard time getting number three
through
uh one why but two when you create
demands
i have been in a college protest myself
when you
she was she she walked out and i won uh
she didn't like a savage but but
when we started when we first walked out
we had no idea or like we didn't have
anything like measurable and then we had
three
very specific demands and so do they
meet them
yeah all right i i think that these are
i think that
now that they're seeing this by the way
they just put this out this is a new
thing since i looked at the article
no you looked at their article five
minutes ago no no
the article i read earlier today this
came out tonight
guys he said we're recording this on
sunday night because we got a busy
monday morning
so if you've listened this far now you
know
now you know our secret that's why we're
so bad at quality
we were not gonna tell anybody well i
was fine telling people you were just
with the vitamin c
right there now we weren't gonna tell
anybody but now now you guys know go
ahead
tonight sunday night so while you guys
are all trying to go to sleep we're
trying to get our lunch money right
uh all right do you have any other
thoughts on the pac-12 no i feel like we
don't even have to abide by the uh by
the 20 minutes like we could spend all
day like what does anybody else got to
do
all right nothing else i was actually
pointing to the line by the way
because i don't need it what you're
gonna need the wine well actually
earlier when we started filming i had my
wine here but then i was like that'd be
people be like oh my god she's an
alcoholic drinking at
eight in the morning so i didn't bring
it out with me but now i can
alright what's going on with spacex okay
guys i didn't know you could do this why
do you say guys like there might be
women watching
do you guys see do you see a boy
all the trolley article or commenters
are men let me tell you that
okay spacex's crew dragon splashed
down in the gulf of mexico completing a
historic
nasa mission the astronauts already back
we started are those the same astronauts
yes i don't think so did doug doug
hurley went up
yes doug and bob are back all right oh
wait
are they back are you sure yes yes
they're back to earth
so it's a two month test it was awesome
i mean it's been great can we officially
say that elon musk is better at space
than nasa
okay ah no i think that they is a joint
effort
they work together teamwork can i just
say like you and i when we work together
to annoy you i was annoyed two minutes
before filming this video but look at me
i am not annoyed right now what's going
on but i will be annoyed later
what i meant to say is can you believe
that we have been doing lunch money
longer than bob and doug have been in
space
there's only two months the pandemic
we're coming up on 100 shows
wait can i ask why they had to splash
down in the water
uh well i think that it's easier to land
in the water by the way if you didn't
watch the live
spacex live stream that we did um one of
the key facts that we learned
is that when the astronauts poop
the poop is saved until they come back
down to earth and then they deal with it
when they get back to earth
but the p the number one is put out into
space and it just disperses
so for all the kids watching for all the
kids watching that's my brother calling
me but i'm not gonna answer because i'm
busy
this is one trash of a show
today's episode is trash
are you is it not trash are you gonna
offend my friends and i
no no not them us oh yeah we're yeah uh
i just told you guys that i used a trash
bag from underneath the sink to bring my
clothes places
all right what's going on but it does
disperse into space
yeah the p just goes all over space so
kids the poop
comes back the p goes out in space so
when they go for a spacewalk they're
kind of walking and pee it's a little
weird
no the universe is so it's infinite
it doesn't it's like when you get an
ocean everyone's like ah nah dis versus
like
i don't know if you did a urine test of
the ocean water i bet you that there
would be a little bit of urine in there
i doubt it
there's somebody who is definitely like
an oceanographer or something i think
that would be more like a map
but there's somebody who will tell us
okay so you ready
yep so college hotel california
college students can now book hotel
rooms for the fall semester
as uncertainty lingers hotels near
college campuses are looking to students
to
fill vacant rooms as the coveted
pandemic casts uncertainty over the fall
semester
and demand from travelers remains
depressed
would you rather live in a college dorm
room or a hotel
it's the same thing well yeah
now one's got a group of people who come
and clean your room every day
oh but you also
are in a hotel so there's usually not a
bunch of space to put a bunch of stuff
well my dorm room was not a bunch of
space to put a bunch of stuff
but the other thing is i'd be away from
like all the other people my age i'd be
in a hotel
no but what if all of your friends all
were on the same floor
in the hotel i would honestly
i would take the hotel because at least
in the hotel you have like amenities you
have like a gym and a pool and whatever
there ain't nothing in the college store
you guys didn't have a gym on your
college campus on the campus but not in
my dorm room or
dorm building yeah but a hotel gym
you're acting like you're
staying at the ritz carlton you're
probably staying at motel 6.
uh would you rather do off-campus
housing or a hotel
is the hotel on campus no it's near the
campus oh no off
off take me off hotels
yeah but hotels are off-campus housing
which one would you prefer
off-campus housing over the hotel yes
yeah i would just want to know where all
of the intellectual
uh conversations are going to be
occurring so that i could further my
education
aka i'd want to know where the party's
going gonna be can we party in the hotel
or not
do we can we do the off-campus housing
or not can we go to the dorm rooms or
not just tell me the little way of the
land then i'll make a decision
guys we're never filming at night again
i kind of like doing it at night
actually better
you have a 55 i have a joke
all right what's your joke okay ready
nope
what do you call an illegally parked
frog an illegally parked frog
rivet no how does that make sense
a toad toad
[Laughter]
toad guys
and ladies this is what i deal with on a
daily basis it's a toad i hope every
single one of you realizes the sacrifice
that i go through to make this show
possible
to make it bearable to make it
informative and educational
this is my co-host
she's fantastic i hope all of you leave
her really nice comments
in the comment section that's it for
lunch monday today while while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our
lunch money here right stay safe
and drink your vitamins see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risks associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends